Senator John McCain continues to
participate in important policy debates
despite his cancer diagnosis the Arizona
senator also took to Twitter to thank
everyone for their outpouring of support
he wrote unfortunately for my sparring
partners in Congress I'll be back soon
Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill and
Nancy a lot of people excited to hear
that he'll be coming back right and
well-wishes still pouring in from every
corner of Congress but in true McCain
fashion the 80 year old senator says
that his colleagues including his best
buddy
need to toughen up I can't think of
anything I've done since 1999
politically in many ways personally that
was worth doing without John McCain
watching from Phoenix told his friend
Lindsey Graham enough is enough he has
called me three times this morning no
more was me Lindsey he is yelling at me
and a buck up
Simon Bukka the two defense Hawks have a
long-running bromance he is loyal to his
friends he loves his country and if he
has to stand up to his party for his
country so bit he would die for this
country I love him to death
it was Graham who noticed McCain's
recent fatigue and urged him to go get
checked the diagnosis glioblastoma an
aggressive form of brain cancer
surprised colleagues who thought perhaps
McCain's melanoma had returned obviously
this is this is tough Arizona's Junior
Senator Jeff Flake is choosing to stay
optimistic
he's got longevity in the family his
mother is a hundred and five there she
just quit driving a couple years ago I
think she's done still perseverance it
seems is a family trait surely attack
squadron won 6-3 Senators know he'll
need to marshal that fighting spirit for
the battle to come
anybody who would not leave a prisoner
of war camp and tell his colleagues were
released as well voluntarily stay there
longer than he should that says all you
need to know about John McCain
mccain is staying involved in policy
conversations from phoenix on thursday
he released a statement making it clear
that he is still going to be a thorn in
the side of the Trump administration
this was a statement about the white
house dropping a program to help the
Syrian opposition and McCain said the
move quote is playing right into the
hands of lad Amir Putin Geoff Nancy
thank you very much